hey what's up guys bus speed
family-friendly Felix here today we have
something special something unique drunk
glasses hilarious though we're killing
holy crap oh okay it's glasses that make
you get this less ugly the god damnit
drunk they make they make you drunk
dries we're coolness this is what
happens when you fall into a battle
never clear oh I've never been this
drunk at work the second you move your
head you it's like reestablish where you
are you really see how apparently these
glasses are made for actual testing of
drunk driving or and stuff like that
they're legit glasses let's see what
crazy stuff BuzzFeed did to check out
these glasses see we are going to do a
variety of activity start the office and
we're going to see how our motor skills
compare from when we're drunk versus
when were sober [ __ ] that was my idea
with the video god damnit Buffy
alright the very shovelling something in
my mouth got it
the keys in the door to me was the
hardest part come on you got a pickup
set gotta take a piss they also in minot
block the line fake fake alright these
are glasses they take away your vision
but alcohol messes with your bout sense
of balance that's in your ear not your
eyes learn grammar breast-feed learn
what you're talkin about
I wasn't fooling anyone like I might
have lost the line but the confident
like just get in the car well clearly
you're bad at faking drunk driving bus
speed disappointed alright so I have the
glasses myself I thought I'd check it
out see if I can spoof them I can show
their theory to be wrong confidence that
you get from being created you really
see how crazy it is to try to like how
they try and end it with like a nice
message like that they upbeat music
whatever caught my kids getting the
truck
and they're one in three good morning
you know right it was all about drunk
driving okay this is the first time I am
everything he's on here we go oh oh my
god I feel so Kay you know what maybe
the balance is a bit [ __ ] up oh oh oh
yeah right I feel so short am i shorter
nope petting Egger sober simple way good
I'd get my sweet dog
come on come on Edgar come yes easy so
[ __ ] with it there's my eyes look
weird
do I look sexy it doesn't look normal
let's put it on difficut done man oh
yeah my name is Felix am I am i back to
do a somersault so hard this it's really
hard it's really hard I don't want to do
it maybe if I'm drunk I can do this okay
oh [ __ ] look oh he's fine
ah ah [ __ ] hell yeah
I feel so dude what is the matter with
you don't make me hit you all right
we're gonna make some tea
it should easy okay
just need to look really close I don't
know how you want this thing and then
plug me
got an extra five oh my god
what is this doing here how do i this is
so hot perfect I can't see anything
ah god damn it oh I did it I don't know
how I did it but I did it damn it what
kind of tea would you guys like don't
worry about that getting dark souls oh
it's so annoying where they we have I
80 bags of tea there you go I got you
okay
nail day I think it's ready
oh god I'm scared this is hot water oh
my god I think I'm gonna hey look at
that boy okay now you guys want some
sugar how many cups
I see three cups I'm guessing this is
the right one drop by sometime nailed it
hey that's pretty good look at that
Edgar can clean this up you want some
eggs
boy I got you eggs damn it's really like
breaking crap
I understand okay we need a bowl what
kind of how many eggs would you like I
feel like I'm hot how to basic right
can't do it oh [ __ ] how do we turn it up
I don't I don't know how this thing
works okay okay we're just wasting eggs
at this point is that it is that all I
have to do
eggs making eggs for drunk not a problem
big I'm [ __ ] good at being drunk man
what can I say this is clearly way too
easy I'm too good at being drunk it's
time to go outside
let's see what drunk is really all about
I forgot about the spits there's no [ __ ]
we got stairs you suggesting there when
you floor are we on driving drunk
Oh [ __ ] tryna mur up G
oh happy happy oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
oh oh
[Music]
it's not even being drunk now
being drunk is cool and all but what if
you get doubles drunk
yeah that one yeah that's some good [ __ ]
we'll get that one please don't try them
on what's back hey you won't be needing
this man
[Laughter]
keep the change thank you very much have
a good one man
I've got a mark and drink this [ __ ]
oh I want you have to drink
I'm ready remember remember kids don't
drink and drive good one oh yeah we're
going slalom baby
haha
as you guys know I'm a really good at
parkour top top-quality parkour man but
how would it look like if you're drunk
you
[Music]
Oh that'll give you strength
what's your [ __ ] problem here honey
maybe putting them on put them on
yeah I don't need to be now I'm gonna go
him
[Music]
Wow okay guys let's just be serious here
for one second it's really important
that if you're drunk do not never ever
go to a skate park that was [ __ ]
crazy what happened the [ __ ] was that I
almost died oh and also and don't drink
and drive or whatever